this today i suspect will be very
constructive and worthwhile for all of
us we're gonna watch some tick-tock
videos some woke
feminist tick-tock videos to be precise
the best kind
uh we know you know tic toc is the place
where the greatest minds come together
ancient greece
had plato aristotle socrates we have
tick-tock accounts those are
those are the philosophers of um modern
society and we're in pretty good shape
because
because of that i think so let's see
what tick-tock tick-tock feminists
specifically have in store for us today
we're going to start with
jess meegan she has 400 000 followers on
tick tock
almost 5 million likes and this video
has the caption
actual comments on my videos do not use
men's approval as a yardstick for your
life
ever make them stay mad hashtag feminism
hashtag aoc womenpower
fyp okay so we're gonna see some actual
comments that people leave on her videos
uh presumably bad comments from men
and anyway sounds pretty harrowing let's
check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
representative yoho put his finger in my
face he called me disgusting
he called me crazy he called me out of
my mind he called me dangerous
representative yoho called me
i am here because i have to show my
parents
that i am their daughter
and that they did not raise me to accept
abuse
from men
[Music]
well i don't know who this
representative yoho is but uh i kind of
like him
so she's lip-syncing to alexandria casa
cortez
complaining she's lip-syncing to aoc
complaining
it's like the weirdest form of karaoke
i've ever this is
this is a more annoying form of karaoke
which i didn't think was possible
um and meanwhile we're supposed to be i
guess impressed by the vicious sexist
comments that she flashes up on screen
here
there's like 12 comments total and not
all of them are from men
i think i'm pretty sure i saw one user
named lucy that she put up on screen
really quick
she was trying to hide that i pretty
sure i saw lucy
that makes sense by the way because
everyone knows
the most vicious comments a woman will
hear in her whole entire life
like the top 100 most vicious comments a
woman will hear
will be from another woman so this is
not
the issue is not men it's you got to
look within your own house but in this
case all the comments are pretty
standard for the internet pretty par for
the course
she thinks she's a badass girl boss
because she she withstood
12 mildly rude comments on the internet
lady
do you want to see my mention sometime
you want to see what people say to me if
you think that's a tragedy my mentions
are
like like a nuclear holocaust in
comparison okay my comment section
should be declared
a natural disaster zone they should
build monuments to my comment section
people will come and weep and
and mourn at it compared to yours
i have people wishing death on my entire
family every day
it's like an everyday occurrence i wake
up in the morning with my my cup of
coffee and i read like my dad used to
read the paper in the morning
but for me i'm reading you know matt
you're the scum of the earth i hope your
whole family is bound together and
tossed into a volcano and
melts slowly you know that kind of thing
that's what i'm reading while i eat my
pop-tarts in the morning okay
so this is not gender specific women
don't have it any worse
on the internet than men do everything
is horrible on the internet for everyone
it's a terrible place we're all rolling
around in the sewer on the internet it's
gross and dirty
but we're here because we've conditioned
ourselves to find some sort of sick
satisfaction in it
that's the case for everyone so you're
not a victim
all right let's try let's try another
one so why do we need feminism in
2021 if you put a man in a room full of
women
he is in heaven and if you put a woman
in a room full of men she is terrified
she she might be terrified uh
if the men in the room have huge gaping
holes in their ears like this guy does
so talk about projection it's you know
the women run screaming out of the room
every time this guy walks into it
mothers covering their their daughter's
eyes people start crying
and he assumes that this is a universal
experience he thinks to himself oh i
guess this is how this is what this is
the effect
men have on women no dude this is the
effect you have on women
all right don't don't don't try to pull
us all into the same
camp as you um and also what the hell
are you talking about when you say that
a man
in a room full of women is in heaven
what i have been in rooms full of women
many times in my life and uh
heaven is not how i would describe the
experience
this lesbian bar doesn't have a fire
exit i was in my house
for example um i was there for part of
my wife's baby shower when she was
pregnant with the twins
and that was not heaven i can tell you
that's that's not my idea of heaven if
that's heaven that i need to rethink my
spiritual goals
like what kind of men is this dude
hanging out with in the first place i
have never heard a guy say hey bro i was
chilling with my wife and her friends
all day yesterday
it was it was heaven we drank mimosas
and talked about pregnancy all day
it was i was so in my element man
i've never heard that or anything like
that ever in my life
um but this is what we find feminists
common theme right when we when we look
at feminist videos they
they exist in a world that is not this
one i don't know what world they're
living in but it's not the one that i
live in
all right let's try the next one here
this is just a reminder for men
that scientists have now discovered a
way for women to impregnate themselves
using their own bone marrow
and the only child that can result from
those pregnancies
are female so we no longer have any need
for you genetically
or physically so you know tread lightly
um that is not true
at all that's not even a little true
it's false no way
not this time so put down the mascara
honey and use your brain for a minute
if you have one holy [ __ ] you [ __ ]
kill her dude you actually think that
women can impregnate themselves
and that isn't a big deal to you you're
talking about it
that that would be the most
consequential scientific innovation
in human history hands down
literally reshaping the human species
and you're all casual about it
like it doesn't even matter it would be
like doing your mascara and yawning and
saying
yeah so uh scientists just discovered
how to go the speed of light and so
i don't know they're going to another
galaxy or something and discovering
aliens like it
this is that's a big deal but it's also
not true
um for the record scientists have not
discovered a way for women to impregnate
themselves
so ladies do not go trying to impregnate
yourself with your bone marrow i don't
know how that would work but don't try
it
don't try it at home don't try it in a
laboratory don't try it anywhere i think
she might be talking about a study that
was done
like 10 years ago or more that
speculated about the theoretical
possibility
that maybe in the future that would be
possible
but then i'm pretty sure that study
turned out there's a lot of plagiarism
and
uh and that was the whole thing and the
point is that no this is not something
that scientists actually know how to do
in the real world
it may be a theoretical possibility but
then again anything that is not
logically impossible is a theoretical
possibility
it's theoretically possible that they
could genetically engineer elephants
who fart pixie dust that cures genital
warts or something i mean
anything like anything that's not
logically impossible is theoretically
possible
um that doesn't mean it's actually going
to happen besides
all that to the side if you don't need
no man as you suggest
then i sure hope you don't expect men to
pay for your meals when you go out on a
date
i hope when that check comes you're
reaching for it every single time
but as we know classic thing we've i i
have never heard of a feminist who
remains a feminist
when the check hits the table doesn't
that doesn't work does it
what's something that's actually
incredibly misogynistic
but everyone just ignores dress code
dress code
let me explain dress code is one of the
earliest symptoms of rape culture in
america
what is rape culture rape culture is
basically victim blaming and blaming a
woman for an assault that happens to her
or other victims
dress code at its core is grown adults
sexualizing little girls and blaming
them for distracting their male
classmates
it teaches young girls from as early as
elementary school that their bodies are
property
and if other people want to sexualize
them that's their fault as little girls
and not the adults sexualizing them or
the boy sexualizing them so what happens
to a little girl when she wears shorts
that are a little too short because it's
all that she can afford
she is punished for it she is told that
it is her fault and she needs to change
so that other people will not sexualize
her that is instilling a victim culture
mindset not only on that little girl but
on
every single person growing up in the
education system in the united states
and that misogyny seeps into how we
treat survivors today in america thank
god i thought these videos were supposed
to be like 30 seconds she went on for
four hours
that's what it felt like to me it's been
84 years
it's some kind of you know like um
what is a christopher nolan movie where
they go to another solar system and
every minute is like 10 years
that's that's kind of what it's like
listening to
a feminist every minute of them speaking
you feel like you aged 10 years
so dress codes are are sexist
um i am so tired honestly of all the
feminist complaints
and i'm tired of all of them this is the
one i might be most tired of
like cry me a river ladies seriously oh
our dress code
it's so oppressive you know what the
standard dress code is for men at least
in formal settings
we have to wear full suits no matter the
season
no matter the temperature and if it's a
wedding and everyone likes to have their
weddings in the summer
and you're in the wedding party then
that means you're wearing a tuxedo
okay long sleeves jacket pants a tie
choking around your neck we're dying of
heat exhaustion in the summer
we can't breathe but we don't complain
about that
men never go around this is sexist but i
have to wear a suit
i don't like it that's my that's like
how my
kids react when they have to get dressed
for church but they're children
you know what we deal with it why
because this is what is expected of us
and we fulfill that obligation
without complaint meanwhile you guys
just can't stop whining anytime
you're given a suggestion on what to
wear oh it's patriarchy i'm being
oppressed
yeah you have a whole cornucopia of
wardrobe options
all of them tailored to the season so if
it's summer you can wear something for
the summer
we our our formal dress code is
we are dressed for sub-zero temperatures
all the time
feels so hot it doesn't matter what what
how hot it is outside
we have one option and if we overheat
and die because of it
we'll do it with a smile on our faces
you can learn something from us ladies
all right let's try uh we'll try a
couple more hi i specifically studied
gender-based trauma and i have two
relevant degrees from harvard on this
let's talk about men who say not all men
this behavior comes from three sources
first this is a male pick me behavior oh
i understand there are men out there who
are acting in abusive ways
but i'm not one of them okay shut up uh
we're gonna we're gonna try
you know i'll move on we'll do we'll do
one more you know what let's we'll try
one more feminist tick tock video
and we'll see if we can find something
that is truly empowering and intelligent
at least more empowering and intelligent
than
what we've heard so far maybe this will
be it this is our last try let's check
this out
hey it's all you hey why while you
working on the flow
fire up that kush as i walk through the
door
cuz you head to toe so you know i'm
getting choked but once i hit it with it
flicks it gonna be big
there it is that is empowerment that is
maybe an argument for dress codes and
all kinds of other codes
but you know what it's at least as
intelligent and coherent as anything
else we've heard
during this segment today